Oh what is going on YouTube you know I
woke up to something quite interesting
the other day hmm
YouTube run up on YouTube and check my
subscriptions to see the uploads and lo
and behold what do we have here again
YouTube has changed again for the
millionth time somebody has decided to
change the mail when I just got used to
the way it was before I don't know how
y'all feel about it
but I don't know what it is LGI baby
let's give why the hell do you keep on
changing the layout when it was fine the
way it was the out we just got used to
the [ __ ] and then somewhere out in
YouTube world somebody would like well
they're happy now
so let's look it up the problem isn't
the switch the problem is that you
changed it and you made it worse have
you heard the saying if it ain't broke
don't fix it
well obviously not cause [ __ ] done [ __ ]
it I love you pickle dick first off ugly
you spent a gajillion dollars
redesigning the website interface that's
all you got
I could give a Korean immigrant half a
sandwich and a green card to do a better
job than this kid I'll take a sandwich
do me favor
oh yeah Jesus saw eg somewhere during a
very important meeting and a hiring
process they had to think that this
ugly-ass job was a good idea
what's with my hands oh is to be paid
for the [ __ ] tell me right now I want
names
you're not gonna do I'm hire a crackhead
to grab your dick and like this [ __ ] on
a brick wall like a match I had a
trainer horse to kick you in your
goddamn over Easter you know what
irritates me the most about the new
layout are those little pop-ups to try
to make you seem like what they did was
a good idea nobody [ __ ] and on top of
that don't pitch
viewers by acting like you're doing us a
favor Oh didn't expect that [ __ ]
I see it all be it all I see on my feet
are celebrity videos premium content and
none of the grassroot stuff that I
connect with let me tell you something
ain't nobody give a [ __ ] about
celebrities on YouTube YouTube mother
made for them if I want to see Justin
Bieber or Nicki Minaj I would watch this
sorry ass on TV riding the giraffe and
pleasure the baby hippo in the stomach
but that's right Nicki I don't give a
[ __ ] about you and your big ass is that
she looks like you smuggling
a family of leprechauns back fish you
know what doesn't I'll give you some
slack because you were found on YouTube
but I still hate your guts what you be
no better than me what cuz you got looks
money cause women tell me skills you one
of the skinny look I am all for
progression and innovation and proving
what can be done better
however this I don't know if anything if
you wanted to make the change on you too
could you have done it and another time
when you just flip the channel little
less than a year ago
and let's just say YouTube for the
benefit of the doubt you really thought
that these changes were great here's the
thing my friends change isn't always
good and being different for the sake of
being different isn't always better
that's why people I spoke my mind I said
what you gonna do to me huh you gonna
shut my channel down cuz I spoke up
don't give a [ __ ] and actually don't
don't do it
understood I need this
you can't believe everything never looks
next paper don't say nothing
they are like they say
[Music]
I really need it I see
raus lie down that's not what I asked